hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bear simulator oh my
goodness am i standing on my hind legs
of his incredible oh hey I got an
achievement
I am bear ah the noble bear stalks his
prey the common pond duck let me get
down and crawl towards him he'll never
see me coming
ah I had you don't soif away oh I lost
my one chance to make a waterfowl friend
are you a bun bun bun bun go die die
haha defeat is the demoralizing Dan
rabbit what did he insult me as he went
along
am I gonna be implicated for bear murder
I swear I didn't know leo who's just
trying to film a movie in my woods who's
just trying to help
what is this no trespassing top-secret
military research compound oh hello hi
oh it's a wolf boy he's rabid he looks
like a Corgi Oh God oh I shouldn't have
done that there's nothing like goat
simulator this is actually me as a bear
and I received another ball an odd
medical condition to have an extra ball
I didn't choose this life water was
chosen for me wasn't born a fruit like
you